the movie starts off with a group of
teenagers having a party at the beach
marking the start of their spring break
one of the girls named Heather records
their celebratory moments while two boys
Vance and Gilbert who have just
discovered a large ball covered in a
strange gooey substance in a distance
bring it over to show their friends the
curious and excited teenagers play with
the ball unaware that it will be the
cause of their Doom another teenager
Mitch encourages everyone to put their
cell phones in a plastic bag so that he
can put them in the trunk of a car he
wants to make sure that no one will post
compromising photos or videos online
everybody agrees to do so and they take
out their funds from their pockets and
dump them in the bag as the party
continues Heather's camera shifts to
focus on Vance who is busy drawing dirty
sketches on Gilbert's cheek while he is
passed out the following morning Mitch
and his best friend Kaye find themselves
in the Lifeguard Shack while Jonah
kayle's boyfriend wakes up in a nearby
car alongside his classmate Shanda in
the back seat Vance and his girlfriend
Ronnie are also Awakening Gilbert on the
other hand wakes up with his lower half
stuck in a trash barrel the result of a
prank after he passed out another
teenager Marsha who had fallen asleep on
a picnic table wakes up to find herself
topless however the rest of the
teenagers including Heather who is video
recording the party the other day are
missing leaving behind only a collection
of empty sleeping bags kale sees Mara
topless on the table and jokes about it
the latter accuses Heather for putting
her in this predicament but just then
she starts feeling uncomfortable and
rows up in the sand in the meantime Kaye
Witnesses a bird being strangely
engulfed by the sand as a result she
quickly warns Mara not to get out of the
table however Marsha feeling unwell has
already set foot in the ground below
moments later her foot gets stuck in the
sand as if something is pulling her from
the ground below visibly distressed and
disoriented she uses her hand to get the
foot out this turns out to be a huge
mistake as she loses her balance and
eventually gets engulfed by the
mysterious sand in an attempt to assist
her Vance gets out of the vehicle and
runs towards her but as soon as he
touches the sand his feet get stuck
causing him to fall on one side Mitch
throws a boy to help him but sadly it is
too late Jonah also attempts to get out
of the car to save Vance but Shanda
warns him of the consequence and stops
him from getting out soon after the sand
Gorly consumes Vance's face and body as
he meets the same fate as Marsha the
rest of the friends are horrified to see
Vance and Mara being ens snared by a
mysterious creature having witnessed the
most disturbing thing yet they begin to
theorize about their current situations
Jonah observing the mysterious ball from
the previous night which is now cracked
theorizes that it was actually an egg
whatever has been hatched from it has
burrowed beneath the sand causing
widespread Devastation the group finds
themselves in a tough spot because their
phones are locked in the car trunk when
Jonah tries to start the car they learn
that its battery is dead from leaving
the headlights on all night in an
attempt to understand what's going on
Kaye places her Palm near the sand just
then thin fibers looking sub substances
emerge from the sand trying to reach her
Palm at the same time Gilbert who is
stuck in a trash barrel wakes up and
starts to fret he is unable to move half
of his body causing him to panic his
friends warn him about the sand but
Gilbert believes they are once again
joking around with him after much
convincing he stays still for a while in
the meantime Kaye rummages through the
Lifeguard shack trying to find anything
that could be helpful to them she then
asks Mitch what happened the other night
he assures her that they only had a few
drinks believing that she was asking
about them but Kaye was actually asking
about the deadly creature and The
Disappearance of the rest of their
friends after going through the cabin
Kaye finds a sunscreen and throws it
over to her boyfriend Jonna the group
then relieves themselves of the
scorching heat using the cream suddenly
Kaylee has something in mind she
attempts to find where the creature
lurking in the sand extends using the
hot dogs she found in the cabin she then
tosses them around the beach to identify
the creature's boundaries sadly their H
to get out of the beach dwindles when
they realize the creature is OCC
occupying a significant area of the
beach Shanda then suggests they wait for
help because it can be too dangerous to
try and Escape but Ronnie reminds them
that no one is coming to save them since
it is spring break just then Jonah comes
up with a clever plan using surfboards
as a bridge to reach the picnic table
while doing so he tells Kaye that he
wants to talk with her however she is
upset about him spending the night with
Shanda in the same way Jonah believes
Kaye spent the night well with Mitch in
The Lifeguard Shack hinting that they
might have slept together while attemp
to reach the table Jonah nearly slips
off the surfboards giving the creature
enough time to raise its small tentacles
the tentacles then begin to cut Jonah's
abdomen injuring him in the process
despite the pain he quickly leaps on the
table saving himself at least for now he
then experiments with the small
tentacles he grabs a banana and places
it on the ashes of the bonfire from the
previous night surprisingly the banana
doesn't get engulfed in the sand when
placed on the ashes this means the
creature avoids the remains of the
bonfire indicating a fear of fire he
then shares this vital piece of
information with his friends suddenly
Jonah starts feeling uncomfortable and
vomits blood he feels as though the
creature is trying to pierce through his
bruised stomach although disoriented he
manages to throw some soda cans to his
friends before passing out on the table
meanwhile the creature seems to be smart
enough to move away the surfboards and
flatten the car tires Bonnie and shander
refuse to sit by so they try to get the
phones from the car trunk under the
scorching Sun sadly Ronnie ends up
crushing her finger in in the process
thankfully a beach patrolman arrives
catching the group's attention he then
tells the group that the beach is closed
and that they shouldn't be there Kaye
and her friends try to warn him about
the creature under the sand and strictly
advise him not to get out of his vehicle
in the meantime we see that Gilbert is
starting to bleed from being stuck in
the barrel for far too long the
patrolman believes the teenagers are
high so he ignores their call
surprisingly he walks on the sand
unharmed thanks to his boots nich then
realizes the significance of the
Footwear and tells tells the patrolman
that he is unharmed because of his
strong boots unfortunately the patrolman
continues to misinterpret the situation
assuming the group is on drugs he
attempts to help Gilbert but the big guy
seems to be too heavy to be lifted from
the barrel Ronnie and Shanda cry for his
help as well but he ignores and taunts
them in response the patrolman then asks
Mitch and Kaye to come down from the
shack but they refuse to oblige to his
orders consistantly warning him of the
deadly creature they continue to tell
him that the creature has killed several
of their friends now irritated the
patrolman reaches for his pepper spray
but accidentally drops his car keys in
the sand as he reaches down to retrieve
them his hand gets stuck in the sand
soon after the creature's small
tentacles start to feed on his hand he
quickly grabs the pepper spray from
another hand and uses it to temporarily
subdue the creature but despite this the
lower part of his arm is completely
consumed causing him to scream in shock
and pain he is then ultimately pulled
into the sand the only good thing is
that Kaye manages to secure the pepper
spray inspire ired by the pepper spray's
temporary deterrent effect Mitch hatches
a plan he believes he can reach the
patrolman's truck by Dawning flip-flops
and wrapping his feet with towels soaked
in pepper spray Shanda tosses him a
towel from the car but as Mitch tries to
catch it the railing of the shack breaks
causing him to fall into the sand
unfortunately he also meets a gruesome
fate at the hands of the creature the
rest of the group are heartbroken to see
another friend lose his life right in
front of them Kaye though briefly
saddened then takes charge of the
situation she starts by instructing
Shanda to grab the broken railing she
tosses another one before throwing over
some towels in the car once all the
equipment is in place she jumps off the
Lifeguard Shack and successfully lands
on the car regaining her posture she
first punches Shanda for flirting with
Jonah and then tells her barely
conscious boyfriend to hang in there
following this the two girls help free
Ronnie's trapped fingers from the car
trunk Kaylee then instructs Shanda to
use broken pieces of the railings as a
bridge to reach Janna on the picnic
table Shanda success successfully
crosses the makeshift bridge and
encourages the others to do so as soon
as possible in the meantime Gilbert
realizes he has unintentionally cut his
stomach while trying to escape from the
trash barrel as a result he has alerted
the creature to his presence Kaye and
Ronnie carefully navigate the makeshift
bridge to reach Shanda and Jonah
unfortunately tragedy strikes when
Ronnie stumbles at the last step when
she becomes distracted by the dripping
blood from her finger despite kayle's
efforts with the pepper spray to subdue
the creature Ronnie sadly gets pulled
into the sand in desperation Shanda
follows through with Mitch's plan
running to the patrolman's truck with
pepper sprayed towels wrapped around her
feet the group experiences a fleeting
moment of Celebration when she succeeds
in doing so however Gilbert Falls victim
to the creature being pulled through the
bottom of the barrel as the creature's
tentacles grow larger and more menacing
the group realizes that the creature has
now grown extremely big because it has
eaten many people just then it starts
attacking the truck causing Shanda to
lose her balance and be knocked on
conscious on the truck as night falls
shander regains Consciousness finding a
self-inflatable raft at the back of the
truck she inflates it and throws it on
the ground for Kaye and Jonah to cross
the Sand she helps the pair by first
walking through the bonfire ashes and
then using the inflated raft to
successfully reach the patrolman's truck
once Shanda and Jonah are inside the
truck the ground suddenly starts to
shake it then knocks Kaye back onto the
raft just then a massive glowing
tentacle emerges attacking her managing
to climb on top of the car Kaye
discovers two gas cans on the rear rack
she grabs the first one and attempts to
pour the gas over the creature but fails
miserably regardless she is not willing
to give up easily so she grabs another
can and successfully pours the gas over
the creature she then retrieves a match
from her pocket and sets one of the
large tentacles a blaze following this
Kaye Shanda and Jonah secure themselves
inside the truck with the creatur's
tentacles bashing at them eventually the
attacks cease and in the silence Kaye
and Shanda sadly realize Jonah has
succumbed to his injuries the two girls
mourn the loss of their friends and find
solace in each other as they fall asleep
in the morning they are awakened by a
man tapping on the car window expressing
concern for their well-being the girls
unbelievably note the absence of the
creature traumatized they walk across
the sand as the man calls for an
ambulance the final scene of the movie
shows the creature revealed as a
gigantic jellish lurking underwater and
heading towards another Beach crowded
with people